[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists it's beginning to
look a lot like christmas
and you know what that means
it's beginning to look a lot like the
christmas
shopping
season on today's episode we're going to
talk about christmas gifts
getting them giving them and sometimes
saying no to them as a minimalist then
this thursday on the minimalist private
podcast ryan and i are going to discuss
joyous time specifically focused on the
holiday season and the many things like
gifts obligations spending debt
expectations
and overbearing family members that
interrupt our joy during this supposedly
most joyous time of the year you can
check that out at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
our first question today is from darwin
i sometimes feel bad about not giving a
christmas gift to someone because they
might feel bad if i forgot about them
how do i deal with this
ryan i i saw this um instagram post here
which i want to share with you
this is from no chill and you can see
the caption there on the left can you
read that for us dear friends your
christmas gift this year is me that's
right another year of friendship
your membership has been renewed
your christmas gift this year is me
that's pretty good i think that's where
we start with a question like this and i
thought this was an important question
to start with darwin thank you you know
i think that well unfortunately
most of us care more about what other
people think of us
than our own contentment
and if you care more about what other
people think of you then you care about
your own contentment joy happiness peace
then you're going to make yourself
miserable trying to please everyone else
now it doesn't mean that trying to
please everyone is bad
i really enjoy when people around me
experience joy yeah in fact joy can be
contagious
here's a misnomer though
we think we're going to get joy from
beginning of gifts
we get temporary pleasure
it's sort of it activates the serotonin
in our brains and allows us to
feel a burst of something that we
mistake
as joy
and we're afraid that if i don't make
other people joyous
well then i'm ruining the holiday season
i'm i'm worried they're going to they're
going to think poorly about me i'm going
to feel bad
because they feel bad because i forgot
about them
so
you know it's fascinating ryan i can
kind of
it's this time of year in particular
it's almost like i can smell the debt
and the anxiety
around that debt in the air yeah the
average person is going to spend about a
thousand dollars this year on christmas
gifts wow man it really is it gets it's
just more and more every year too every
year in fact i have this report let me
read this real quick ryan the nrf
which is the national retail federation
predicts the highest holiday retail
sales on record in 2021
holiday spending has the potential to
shatter previous records as the national
retail federation today's forecast that
holiday sales during november and
december will grow between 8.5 and 10.5
percent over 2020. wow in 2020 was
growth as well right so last year it was
843 billion this year it's
859 billion man that's almost a trillion
dollars ryan you want to explain to
folks how much a trillion dollars is
it's a lot yeah if you started to spend
uh one dollar every single second
it would take you over 31 000 years to
spend a trillion dollars and that's if
you didn't sleep that's if you didn't
sleep 24 hours a day every single second
one dollar two dollars three dollars
four dollars five dollars six dollars 31
000 years that math is correct you all
can check me on that um but yeah if you
spent a million dollars a day
since the birth of the buddha you still
wouldn't have spent a trillion dollars
by now that's like some dan bilzerian
kind of spending dude it's yeah right
it's well it's funny how like we hear a
trillion dollars um you know the
government just passed this trillion
dollar
infrastructure deal our consumer debt is
you know 12 trillion over 12 trillion
dollars
it's almost now like it's it's used so
much that we it doesn't seem like a lot
to us and that's definitely a problem
right in fact because we get confused we
say million and millionaires and
billionaires right and we talk about
millio a million dollars it's like a
million seconds is like 12 days right
right a billion seconds is like 32 years
right it's so it's nearly impossible for
us to distinguish the difference in our
head
because they sound very similar trillion
is way beyond that as you said
31 000 years
in order to spend a trillion dollars if
you kept spending every second the
staggering part of what you just said is
if you went out and spent a million
dollars every single day it's nuts you i
mean it's impossible for thousands of
years yeah since since the birth of the
buddha yes that's unbelievable yeah and
so what we're doing is we're spending
ourselves into this whole debt anxiety
stress discontent overwhelm
we're consuming things
to try to make people happy
but that is actually making us miserable
now why are we doing this because we are
more concerned with what other people
think about us we're more concerned with
maintaining a tradition that is no
longer working for us however we have
some alternatives i have another article
here from our good friend joshua becker
he runs the website called becoming
minimalist he was on our first film on
netflix which is called minimalism
and this article is called if there was
ever a year to give experiences for
christmas rather than physical
possessions this
is the year heck yeah the subtitle here
is inflation supply chain issues delayed
mail
if there was ever a year to start giving
experiences for christmas rather than
physical possessions this is the year a
few years ago my friend and his family
of six
started a new holiday tradition rather
than spending money on a bunch of stuff
we don't need we started a new christmas
tradition he said every day of the week
after christmas until new year's we did
something fun as a family let's start
stop for a second ryan talk about
tradition
we use that word tradition and it often
sounds good
but
traditions can be great they can also be
incredibly limiting disempowering
anxiety producing yeah and the problem
is we we cling to these old traditions
without ever questioning them sure i
mean if you do something for the sake of
tradition then yeah it can be a
detriment for sure i mean what i love
about this
is you know with these experiences that
becker is talking about he's still
showing the people around him
that he loves them he wants to add value
to their lives and that's that's really
what darwin is questioning here like how
can i how can i still show people
that i love them how can i still be
compassionate towards others without
buying them a gift um i'll tell you
though man like
so i think experiences are great to give
and that's what i would definitely
choose first first of all any anything
else that's what mariah and i gift each
other um experiences or you know maybe
consumables but
my mother
um she
basically had expressed to me one time
she's like you know it really is
frustrating you don't acknowledge me on
mother's day or uh my birthday this is
like 10 or so years ago
and uh she's like you know i'm not
asking for a lot just like you know just
acknowledge me that i exist um so i
would call her
and uh i sent her like some flowers so
there's an ephemeralness there i sent
her some chocolates you know something
like that
and
all it took was like a little bit of
that to make her feel seen
and to show her that i do love her now
is that how i feel like i should show
love no i don't think flowers and
chocolate is a way to show love but she
feels yeah that that's a way to be shown
love so i think there's this balance
between
um you still want to respect other
people's preferences to a certain extent
uh you know as long as it doesn't fall
uh as long as it doesn't
cross over these lines that you've drawn
in your life with your values or maybe
your beliefs
um
but yes it's so there's a balance what
i'm trying to get at is there's a
balance between
uh someone thinking about you like oh
wow like my mom thinking about me ryan
loves me ryan sees me ryan appreciates
them as mother versus someone who's
looking at it and saying i can't believe
you only spent 100 on me right that's
not love and there's i don't know where
that balance falls but i know with me
it's usually it's with the cons anything
past consumables or an experience like
that's where i start to um not care
about what other people think about me
what you're saying is your mom sees that
as a way to acknowledge her and it's not
an unreasonable expectation that she has
sure if for however she was like i can't
believe you don't buy me a new car every
christmas right you'd be like haha right
good luck with that right right and it's
easy to dismiss that and so i i want to
be careful here because what ryan and i
aren't saying is well just jump up and
say ba humbug screw the holidays as a
minimalist no perhaps there's a better
way to create a new tradition one that
doesn't stress you out because let's be
honest for a moment the average person
in your life is also stressed out by the
holiday of obligatory gift-giving yeah
and they don't want to have to give you
something and they don't really care
about the thing that you're going to
give them if you're merely giving it to
them out of obligation
you can tick-tock that danny unknown
now let's return to this article here
sometimes it was simple
pizza and a movie other days it was more
extravagant horseback riding etc but we
took that money so every day after
christmas they took that money and they
would they would have spent on physical
gifts so let's say you were going to
spend 800 this christmas season they
took that money and spread it out over
the week making sure everyone got to do
something they really enjoyed
after the holiday season i asked him how
it went he replied with a smile on his
face best decision we ever made a new
family tradition has been born we're
already looking forward to next year
that's not something that
people can often say in fact here's the
question that i want to pause it back to
darwin here
when darwin says i sometimes feel bad
about not giving christmas gifts to
someone because they might feel bad
well first off are you manufacturing
that belief yourself
is it actually you who feels bad because
you feel that peer pressure of society
the cultural imperative to buy a
physical material good and if so you can
let that go
that you just stop clinging to it that's
how you let that go but here's the other
question to ask yourself will this
actually matter a year from now
that that tie clip you got your friend
right the um oven mitt that you
purchased your significant other will
any of this matter a year from now or
worse
will it matter in a negative way well it
matter because a month from now six
months from now 12 months from now it's
just taking up all this extra space in
your house there's a story of jason and
jennifer kirkendall in our book love
people use things
where
they actually saw our documentary like a
lot of people did on christmas morning
2016. yeah and she was contrasting the
simple lives on the screen
with
all of these presents that had been
unwrapped their two kids and both of
them unwrapped all these gifts and the
kids had already forgotten about most of
the gifts and the present that jason
bought jennifer with their group credit
card they went to debt for a christmas
gift
it was in a drawer and sort of
uh unwelcome unthought of yeah discarded
in a way and so we discard our things
without letting them go we continue to
cling to them out of obligation let's
return to the text here
when we found minimalism 12 years ago
becker says we also decided to change
how we celebrated the holiday season
limiting our children's gifts to three
one thing they need
one thing they want and one experience
to share with the family i think it's a
beautiful boundary hey you want
something great we'll get that for you
for christmas right yeah
here's something you need we'll get that
for you for christmas
and then here's an experience so we're
going to talk about some of those
experiences here in a moment what a good
good example of how uh minimalism does
not have to be deprivation
because i think often like people think
well
like they'll see you know uh a picture
of your home and there's not a ton of
art on the walls i couldn't live in such
a gray contrasted stark white
you know quiet room and it's like
okay cool like josh can i'm not asking
you to right exactly yes you could damn
it right and you will right
but they associate that with like well
he's a minimalist so of course he's not
gonna have paintings or he's a
minimalist of course he's not gonna have
whatever
uh but that's that's not the case i mean
that's just like one little snippet
really it's it's what is what adds value
to your life man but this is great
because it shows you that it's okay to
have things that you want that's right
it's okay to have some non-essential
goods in your life right yeah the
non-essentials as long as they're not
junk actually add value to our life the
problem is especially with the holiday
so we've got the no junk rule right
which darwin you can download for free
we've got the 16 rules for living with
less the minimalists.com rule book it's
the minimalist rule book download it for
free it's not really rules they're
boundaries that you can set up for your
own life for your family's life getting
their buy-in as well one of those is the
no junk rule everything you own fits in
one of three piles it's either essential
non-essential but value-adding or it's
junk most of the things we buy during
the holidays this
859 billion dollars are spending this
year the vast majority of it is on junk
ryan you sometimes talk about how we
spend 1.2 trillion dollars a year on
non-essential goods
most of which is
junk yeah we're buying junk we're
putting wrapping paper on it and then
offloading that junk on someone else
going into debt to buy things that
people don't want they don't need here's
something that you may want to consider
instead of buying gifts for everyone in
your family just buy them a trash can
and that way they can put all the
unwanted gifts in that trash can and
drag it right out to the curb
on christmas morning
all right so um
he talks about these boundaries here one
thing you want one thing you need one
experience with the family to celebrate
holidays differently you need to make
the decision to do so i think that's the
thing if you keep doing the same thing
you did before and you felt discontent
from it or maybe it was working for a
season for you but now you realize like
this is really stressing me out yeah
there are too many obligations i have to
go to too many families houses i have to
buy too many gifts i have to do too many
white elephant work party
gift exchanges remember those dude those
are fun i'm not going to lie
it's garbage
it is garbage but it's entertainment for
sure and we'll actually talk about how
we can have fun but in a way that you're
not
stressing yourself out over it yeah so
um he goes on to say and if there was
ever a year to try out a change this is
the one
news reports are already surfacing that
this holiday season may be filled with
increased challenges and frustrations uh
that's the supply chain issues we've
experienced it ourselves dude you you've
seen four video tours if you're a
patreon supporter by the way shout out
to our live stream we're live streaming
this on patreon we'll get to you in a
moment get some of your comments and
your questions about christmas gifts but
we've done four video tours of our
studio space the studio build out and
we've been building the studio out for
most of this year and it's taken a long
time for a few reasons one is we wanted
to be intentional but two
there are some serious supply chain
issues yeah the podcast desk that we
have coming in is gorgeous but it was
stuck in customs for over a month yeah
and i don't know if it was just on a
boat on shore somewhere or what where i
don't know what they did but it was
stuck there right and certain parts
being able to get different things took
forever this tabletop for this table
that we're using right now took forever
to get and so
there's some lighting cameras cables the
sdi cables that jordan is using they
took months for those to arrive oh wow
for a cable yeah the chip short there's
a lot of shortages man that's crazy and
so there's gonna be more of that this
year than ever so we're at the um
the u-haul place because we had to move
those paintings yesterday and the guy
was talking about how uh
these u-haul trucks are constantly being
targeted uh to be stolen and one of the
things he mentioned well i forget what
it was but there's something to do with
the chip shortage they could like
basically take uh you know take it apart
re-stamp with different serial numbers
and because of the chip shortage and the
different supply chain shortages like
there's a booming business right now
with like stealing u-haul trucks
essentially that's right it's crazy that
yeah it in the the reason that well
we're
we have the scarcity mindset right as
soon as something isn't available we
want it more um it's the reason that
retailers do this right act now supplies
are limited door buster sales black
friday this is actually coming out um a
few days after black friday
but
that used to be the busiest shopping day
of the year and some years it still is
but now cyber monday also the saturday
before christmas because last minute
scrambling for things last minute
scrambled day
you're right dude i worry about the
shortages that are happening now how
much of them are fabricated
and how much of them are actually uh
real problems i think it's more of the
latter but there's certainly what's
happening because you have these real
problems you have corporations and
different entities who are taking
advantage oh yeah we can charge more for
this because yeah if we fake a shortage
yes i mean that's
it's essentially what the diamond
industry is absolutely yeah that's the
most erotic example of it yes in fact
it's not a parody but it seems like a
parody right like hey you know what
we'll sell these stupid rocks to people
for thousands of dollars right yeah cool
yeah it's nuts and you know what how
we'll do it
diamonds are forever right
everlasting devotion and love
is represented by this rock that some
kid lost an arm procuring in sierra
leone so that you can have a shiny thing
on your finger or chain or ear or
whatever right and so um that's
particularly grotesque
now uh not that there's anything
inherently wrong in fact here's the
problem the problem is when we assign
the meaning to it right yeah in fact you
can make diamonds in a lab now that are
precise better yeah and that are
actually better quality yes than like
the regular carbon diamonds yeah and
they're well they're carbon they're
they're real diamonds right so we're not
talking about cubic zirconiums or
whatever they're called we're talking
about real diamonds but they're
manufactured they're not found in nature
and no one had to lose their limbs or
life in order to procure them right
they're not quote real even though
they're more real than the quote real
ones isn't that interesting so like
they can make a perfect diamond flawless
yes in a lab with real carbon
that isn't worth as much
as something that was found naturally
and has like imperfections with it right
to the extent where like they even have
like different you know with diamonds
different scale they got like the color
scale and the carbon scale and what you
can see in there and that that imperfect
thing
is
less quality but more expensive i mean
that is that's how pernicious the
diamond industry is and i would even
understand that if diamonds were
actually rare but what de beers is doing
they have a monopoly monopoly on
industry they only release what is it
like two to five percent of the diamonds
so 95 of them are are hoarded to prevent
people from
from buying them because if you flood
the market with that much supply podcast
sean will tell you that price will go
down significantly right he's our
resident economist here right
and so uh that's how markets work and so
if you if they just flooded the market
with all the diamonds the price would go
down significantly now what have they
done they've created an artificial
limit on the amount that can be
purchased well what does that sound like
it sounds like every store down on
fairfax right now yeah they're yeah
what about this week's clothing drop the
new supreme drop what's going on at the
hundreds what all of these things that
are going on to create this false sense
of scarcity and to make you what to make
you feel incomplete you're incomplete if
you don't buy this and oh by the way
you're not a good husband or lover or
daughter or son or parent if you don't
buy the right things for the people you
love this is the only way you can show
your love but of course that's absurd we
hear that gift giving
is a love language but that's like
saying pig latin is a romance language
it's total nonsense you can drop that
right now gift giving is not a love
language it's
well adding value is a love language
dude it's funny um it makes me think
about we were in gold coast and somebody
asked they're like you know i don't like
gift giving is my love language which
let's say it is okay like i i agree it's
probably it's not a love language but
let's let's just for a minute give this
person the benefit of the doubt that
gift giving is their love language and
he was like how do i show my love
uh like a minimalist when my love
language is gift giving my first thought
is is
don't you want to show people love the
way that they want to receive it not the
way that you want to give it uh you know
what i'm saying yeah so i mean right
there kind of like breaks down for me
the whole gift-giving is a love language
yeah and i think what you're what you're
exposing there is there are some people
who want to receive gifts because they
might need something they want something
or whatever
and if it's appropriate fine however
if it feels like an obligation it
probably is if it's stressing you out
that is a sign
to let go not of the things but of the
obligation to give
physical goods to other people
at christmas time i'm going to continue
this article here it's almost finished
inflation is reaching new levels we
haven't seen in decades yeah i think at
the highest inflation in 31 years this
year
it really is millions of people just
lost pandemic era unemployment benefits
an important phenomenon took place in
2020
people oh this is gross man but it makes
sense people began spending more on
goods and less on services as a
percentage of personal spending
non-consumable goods increased six
percent in 2020 while services fell by
seven percent
some sectors falling by 20 to 30 percent
like recreation travel etc
all that to say in 2020
most americans and i think this spreads
to the western world as well
most americans spent the year
purchasing more and more physical
possessions and fewer and fewer services
and experiences dude they're stuck at
home yes of course
amazon's doing awesome
they yeah they they offer you a a home
shopping experience you're right i like
rude the day that um and maybe we've
talked about this in the past but like
i i believe in virtual reality and in an
augmented reality especially like
there's going to be some really cool
stuff i think on the horizon but what i
worry about is with technology like that
you're also going to have the bad stuff
on the horizon which is uh you know
you're going to be able to go to a
shopping mall basically with your vr
headset and have this shopping mall
experience from home yeah um yeah i mean
yeah if you can do it from home yeah
it's going to increase for sure
especially during a pandemic that's
right and so he goes on to say that if
our homes weren't full enough in 2019
they're even fuller in 2021
that's a double entendre full
enough
we're all fools for what we consume
we're consuming so much you look in the
mirror ah and we all experience it right
that that regret
the what what it was it's even there's a
return
um
nomenclature for this um buyer's regret
briar's remorse remember that yeah sean
used to manage a bunch of inventory and
so like so one of the return reasons was
buyer's remorse yeah we all have buyers
remorse because we're buying a bunch of
things that aren't adding value to our
lives
he uh he goes on to say
most of your family and friends desire
what
if there's every year to start giving
experiences for christmas rather than
physical possessions this is the year
most of your family and friends desire
that anyway
that's the key
most of the people you know are also
overwhelmed by the holidays now he says
every year
i post a list of 52 clutter-free gift
ideas let me hand this over to you ryan
but this is from joshua becker
this so far has over 12 million people
have shared this nice and and seen it so
52 clutter-free gifts experiences
classes memberships consumables you want
to read some of your favorites on here
ryan uh concert tickets that's one that
mariah and i definitely do uh movie
passes yeah theater tickets
um
bowling passes i love bowling
daddy daughter date that's what i'm
gonna give you josh oh
it's for you and ella
uh with classes you can do cooking i
would love to take some cooking classes
we live in l.a man just like again this
is the seven on the enneagram uh myself
we're like i feel like i don't do enough
in los angeles but one of those things
is cooking there's so many cooking
classes and like yeah awesome cooking
classes i should which marine i should
totally do that
um
yeah music painting art home brewing
scuba diving
uh consumables you got fruit baskets
i love baskets made of fruit
consumables flowers i love eating
flowers
i actually have had flowers at a nice
restaurant i took backsteel once they
had like these edible bougainvilleas
there were a couple on there that really
stood out to me uh which ones which one
stood out to you indoor rock climbing oh
it was one um now we're in l.a so you
can just do outdoor rock climbing but
for this time of year if you're in most
parts of the country indoor rock
climbing makes a ton of sense right a
great experience escape rooms i've never
been to an escape room i don't know i
mean you don't you're not you and bex
hate games yeah yeah i'm not saying for
me but i'm saying for most people yes i
was gonna say i don't know if you would
like it in escape room i wouldn't i can
tell you right now i don't like
pure joy you would hate it
yeah it's uh
you know what any of these things that
require fun
count me out but here's the thing i also
understand that sometimes i'll do some
of these things like like rock climbing
is not pure joy but it is like in the
moment uh and that's what we call type 2
fun oh is it yeah tell me about this so
type you've never heard of this alright
so type 1 fun is it like type 2 diabetes
uh it's similar but no no sorry so type
one fun is it's fun
from start to finish an escape room
would be pretty much a type one fun okay
because you get in there you're playing
a game the entire time there's some
problem solving but it's pretty but it's
pretty much fun from start to finish
yeah rock climbing is type 2 fun where
there's a lot of work up front
and like as you're going through the
work you're getting closer and closer to
the finishing point and when you finish
like that's when you can have the fun so
you got to work for all that fun
and then there's type 3 fun which um i
don't know maybe rock climbing would be
type 3 but it's type 3 fun is is work
from start to finish okay it's like and
then you just like like actually going
to the gym would be type three fun okay
yeah yeah yeah i i prefer
two and three to one yeah and i i sort
of you know david foster wallace has a
great essay called a supposedly fun
thing i'll never do again it's about a
cruise ship which is type one fun right
but it's sort of i really want to do a
cruise ship oh wow we could do the
minimalist cruise well no there's
something about having that experience
because i know people and know of people
so dfw and then i also have some friends
who are the bergamot uh who they've
opened up for us and um yeah great band
check them out bergamot uh they
did a cruise ship for like a month and
they were talking about how it was like
again this thing that like they were so
grateful that they had the opportunity
to do that they'll never do again
yeah that's exactly i i went on one when
i was like 17 i think and yeah i can't
imagine ever going back podcast channel
i'll put a link to the bergamot in the
show notes i'm also going to put a link
to this
article from joshua becker and a link to
these 52 clutter free gifts
on facebook this is from joshua becker
as well shout out to joshua becker he
has a new book coming out by the way
it's called
things that matter i think we'll bring
him on the podcast it comes out next
spring i believe thank you we'll bring
him on the podcast we've done live
events with him before he was one of the
people who originally inspired us to
become minimalists and eventually the
minimalists i've got some other articles
here as well ryan we don't have time for
them i will address them on the maximal
episode on the middle most private
podcast this thursday
and oh
darwin let's send you a couple of
tickets if you want an experience i
don't know what city you're in but uh
let's send you two tickets to the love
people use things tour that's getting
ready to start up so anyone who wants to
buy some
gifts for anyone who might find value in
minimalism you know the best experience
you could buy someone tickets to our
event tickets to less
it's a lot of people use things tour 11
cities left we're going to be in new
york in boston washington dc and toronto
and chicago and columbus in minneapolis
and vancouver and seattle and san
francisco and los angeles
early
2022 it's in january and february
finishing up the love people use things
tour we've already done nine events all
20 events are available over on patreon
as well patreon.com the minimalist so
darwin whatever city you're in i'd love
to send you a couple tickets at no cost
whatever cities closest to you the
minimalists.com tour to find a city near
you
alabama we're going to check in with
some patreon supporters
on the live stream do we have a comment
at this point anyone commenting
questions as well we could probably get
to the questions on the maximal yeah um
plenty of questions that we can get to
later a lot of comments thanking you for
the advanced warning that we're going uh
live um a lot of people really
appreciated that
um we also have a lot of people talking
about um like the experience based gifts
um they also help out with small
businesses angela said down here um
especially getting back on their feet
after the pandemic that's a great point
yeah um a couple of other things that
were recommended were um axe throwing
tickets um as an experience based gift
you would hate
so much fun you would hate actually oh
it's so much fun it really is
i've done that twice in l.a so far it's
yeah it's awesome i think you bring up a
great point is also if you are going to
buy anything whether it's consumables
experiences etc supporting local mom and
pop shops small businesses indie
businesses as opposed to big box
retailers
often helps people thrive at a time
where it's really difficult for small
independent businesses to thrive ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and your comments to
937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones strangely we answer as many as we
can now during the lightning round this
is where ryan and i
answer your questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and now you can
find all of our minimal maxims in one
place
minimalmaxims.com sarah has a question
for us in alabama how do minimalist
families handle christmas stockings each
year we feel pressured to fill the
stockings with junk food or other
consumables is there any way to get
around the consumerist mentality of
buying more yeah i agree with you i
don't want to buy a bunch of junk
however
i really like this question because it's
my favorite part of the tradition that
and christmas lights which i actually
make part of the experience so we always
take ella out to like a either we'll go
to rodeo drive because they have great
christmas lights and santa is there as
well we've never told her that santa was
real or anything like that but we you
know sort of like cosplay right he
dresses up we pretend and it's fun to
yeah have the magic of imagination
and the stockings the other side so
we'll take her to lights also they have
these crazy beautiful light shows at
different locations we'll go this one in
pasadena that is beautiful there's
another one in long beach i think we're
gonna try this year and so you have
these opportunities to go to these these
light displays which is great but the
stockings
i actually really enjoy the stocking now
what we'll try to do is we'll we won't
get one of the giant ones we'll get our
one that's relatively small and
minimalist stocking sort of now that
deprivation is stocking that's a
different size stocking that's right
it's uh
no what you do if you're a
deprivationist is you give her the stock
and you rip it out of her hands and you
throw it in the trash
and you say bah humbug we're not doing
christmas this year ella and you give
her a good lesson for christmas
eat this lump of coal oh my goodness now
here's here's the thing i enjoy the
stock we'll get her like a smaller one
but then we'll fill it up like because
it's all about perspective right if you
get one of those giant stockings you
fill it halfway it's like oh you didn't
even fill it up but you have a smaller
stocking that's just teeming with things
that she'll actually enjoy so here are
some of the things i'm putting in ella's
stocking this year i wrote them down
this morning
a purple toothbrush
she always enjoys getting a purple
toothbrush
and so these are things that people need
quite often right
magnifying glass
so she can go out and explore nature on
her own and burn ants
actually i don't think she would ever
burn ants uh we just bought her these
chocolate stirring spoons
which i think i'm also gonna get ryan
for christmas as well delicious you know
what i'm talking about though like yeah
the hot cocoa she's gonna eat the spoon
josh
just
give me chocolates
yeah and so uh you get to stir it and
she likes stirring into the hot cocoa
we'll do that there like three different
ones just more like caramel one with
peppermint which she may or may not like
um
oh character band-aids oh i would like
those too
it's not funny how kids just love
band-aids man yes it's like yeah kids
are like they'll make up they'll see
like a little blemish
and they'll be like oh i need a band-aid
right yes
and so i'm trying to see if they have
harry potter ones because you've been in
the harry potter for the last year and a
half or so and she's really sort of out
almost out of the frozen phase even
though she's still she kind of likes it
still but you know it's she's gotten a
bit old for she's eight and a half at
this point actually i don't say half
she's eight
and um she'll be nine eventually never
use the word i would never even talk
about it she's eight and eight and fifty
percent
she's 8.5
at oh movie tickets so finding a movie
for her is challenging because she's
terrified of everything i know we did
watch the first two harry potters and
she didn't freak out she freaked out a
little bit during the second one dude
they get darker and darker too she won't
be able to watch like the last the last
two are like
dark okay anyway well we'll see
if she wants to run she can
she couldn't handle gremlins she cannot
handle harry potter yeah gremlins is
funny though i had no idea why she
thought it was terrifying
uh here i'm getting some art supplies
that's going into the stocking some hair
ties kids love colorful hair ties right
yeah and so um she loses them all the
time and so it's just replenishing some
of the things she might have lost anyway
or outgrown etc and then most important
i'm gonna give her
well i'm gonna give to charity in her
name so she's contributing to charity as
well i don't have time to go through the
whole article we'll go through it on the
private podcast but put a link to this
as well sean this is from the spruce
it's called the top six charities that
help children at christmas time so
things like toys for tots operation
christmas child make a wish foundation
and three others and we'll talk about
those
on the maximal episode this thursday i
got something pithy for you though ryan
because we don't want to be ba humbug
about this
my pithy answer is this
dispossession drives discontentment
let's talk about what dispos this
possession is dispossession is when
someone has something and you actively
take it from them yeah so you've
dispossessed them right now i will also
say that our possessions often
dispossess us they take experiences away
they take part of our life away they
take away our joy quite often but the
same thing is true if you grew up
experiencing this ryan you your father
didn't let you celebrate holidays and it
was a type of dispossession and you sort
of felt left out and so we don't make it
about consumerism for the holidays but
we also don't deprive her of the things
that well she might enjoy getting in the
first place i got spanked for eating a
piece of birthday cake when i was five
oh my god
actually no i was four
well next week we're going to talk about
being in a cult yeah um so tune in next
week we have amanda montrell coming onto
the podcast she wrote a book called
cultish we're gonna talk to you about
whether minimalism could become a cult
and also the cult that ryan grew up in
my little sister um
i forget i gotta have to ask her but she
got punished for eating a birthday uh
cupcake
unbelievable i know man
bear the rod spoil the child anyway
um pick the answer is this don't let
your christmas be consumed by peer
pressured purchasing
alliteration that's right i've noticed
all a lot of our pithy answers have
alliteration in them indeed um
so you know here's the thing is it's
okay to buy things it's okay to give
someone an experience or maybe it isn't
it's a purple toothbrush
but don't be peer pressured as soon as
you let yourself be peered pressured in
the purchasing thanks for christmas it's
gonna ruin your christmas so don't let
that ruin your christmas amen well we
got so much more to talk about ryan but
in alabama you got something for us
first here are some voicemail comments
and insights from our listeners
hi my name is stefania i'm calling from
st paul minnesota i'm calling with a
suggestion for your clothing episode
i've been using these socks called darn
tough it's a company from vermont
they guarantee their socks for life
i think all they sell is soft actually
and while they are a little bit pricey
they do go on sale um and the thought of
having socks that will last either my
entire life or they will be replaced by
the company feels really right like it's
right up my alley
um i've had these socks for over a year
now and they look as good as new
i have had to return one pair and the
company had excellent customer service
so i highly recommend them
hey josh hey ryan
this is in response to your podcast
dealing with criticism
there's a quote that i found recently
that i've been implementing into my life
to really help me
it goes as follows
treat everyone with politeness even
those who are rude to you
not because they are nice but because
you are
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like how do i get my
mother-in-law to stop giving me gifts
how do i say no to family members who
think i'm being snobby and standoffish
simply because i don't want to
participate in gift giving and how can i
give meaningful gifts that my friends
and family will enjoy plus a million
more questions for the minimalists about
the holiday season and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com the minimalists to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalists on tik-tok instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalists
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com or call 406-219-7839
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list on our
website you'll also receive our simple
sunday email newsletter for free and if
you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it